la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance
a été distribué
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal et
adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues j'ai le plaisir de saluer la
présence dans la tribune de neur des
trois questeurs de la Chambre des
conseillers du Royaume du Maroc Monsieur
Mohamed Salem benma Saoud
[Applaudissements]
vos collègues Abdelilah Yves dit et
notre collègue Miloud massidé ils sont
accompagnés par le secrétaire général de
la Chambre des conseillers
notre collègue Christian Campbon
président du groupe d'amitié France
Maroc est présent à leur côté ils ont
rencontré hier nos collègues questions
du Sénat ainsi que le président Roger
carochi et les membres du groupe
d'amitié
la visite de nos collègues questeur est
le jumelage en cours entre nos deux
assemblées
sur le reflet du partenariat qui nous
unit et de l'importance j'y insiste des
relations d'amitié entre la France et le
Maroc
madame la Première ministre mes chers
collègues en votre nom à tous
permettez-moi de souhaiter aux trois
testeurs de la Chambre des conseillers
du Maroc la plus cordiale bienvenue au
Sénat de la République française
[Applaudissements]
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site
je rappelle mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle la nécessité d'observer au
cours de nos échanges les valeurs qui
sont essentielles pour nous le respect
des uns et des autres et bien sûr aussi
celui du temps de parole je donne
immédiatement la parole à notre collègue
Jacques Pernic pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre la semaine dernière
madame la Première ministre présentait
l'ambition France nations verte et vous
y affichiez l'enjeu des mobilités mieux
se déplacer parmi les six thématiques
d'impact direct sur la vie des Français
aux horizons 2030 et 2050 mais mais dès
à présent en 2022 pour 2023 votre
gouvernement se donne-t-il les moyens de
ses ambitions pour les mobilités vertes
au moment où nos transports publics du
quotidien sont plus que jamais
nécessaires qu'il s'agisse du
ferroviaire de région ou des transports
publics
urbains et ruraux au moment où ils
apparaissent bons pour le pouvoir
d'achat bon pour la décarbonation bon
pour la vitalité économique de nos
territoires ne risquons nous pas faute
d'engagement à la hauteur de l'essai se
dégrader ses services de compromettre
les chances d'un New Deal des transports
publics comment ces services publics
essentiels pourraient-ils se maintenir
ces prochains mois sans encadrement des
coûts de l'énergie sans plafonnement des
prix de l'électricité ferroviaire
comment notre train régionaux et nos
futurs réseaux Express métropolitain
pourrait-il prospérer si les pH
ferroviaires déjà les plus élevés
d'Europe continuent d'augmenter comment
nos transports publics pourrait-il
s'équilibrer si le versement mobilité
les employeurs et remise en cause s'il
n'est pas conforté comment réussir un
choc d'offres des transports urbain et
l'électrification des bus comment enfin
avec les moyens limités de votre projet
de loi de finance moderniser un
ferroviaire français qui pourrait
décrocher en Europe monsieur le ministre
quelle réponse concrète maintenant pour
dégager l'horizon des transports publics
et ferroviaires pour vous répondre la
parole et communiste déléguée en charge
des transports le ministre monsieur
Clément baume
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Fernique vous avez raison
d'insister sur le caractère absolument
central du ferroviaire et les transports
publics notre ambition écologique de
neutralité carbone pour 2050
transformation profonde de notre
économie de notre société la première
ministre eu l'occasion de le dire dès
l'arrivée du gouvernement nous portons à
Christophe Béchu le ferroviaire et la
colonne vertébrale de cette mobilité
propre le projet de loi de finance dont
le Sénat aura à connaître dans quelques
jours le démontre déjà mais je le tiens
à le signaler vous avez parlé d'ambition
limitée je ne vous rejoins pas sur ce
point mais je précise une chose que j'ai
l'occasion de dire devant votre
assemblée en commission c'est que le PLF
le retrace pas l'ensemble de l'effort
public et de l'effort d'État en faveur
des mobilités vertes et du ferroviaire
en particulier au total ce sont pour
2023 et c'est un chiffre qui n'a pas été
atteint depuis plus de 15 ans un total
de 12 milliards d'euros qui sont
mobilisés par l'État 4 milliards d'euros
directement dans le PLF si nous ajoutons
les efforts de la Société du Grand Paris
le budget de l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport de France
et beaucoup d'autres encore c'est 12
milliards la moitié plus de la moitié
exactement seront consacré au
ferroviaire nous avons besoin de
poursuivre cette ambition vous avez
souligné à quel point nous devions
entretenir notre réseau ferroviaire nos
transports du quotidien c'est l'ambition
que nous portons et Christophe Béchu je
signale que s'agissant du réseau
ferroviaire français je le dis depuis
que je suis arrivé c'est la priorité
absolue nous avons un contrat de
performance qui a réhaussé de manière
inédite les crédits annuels pendant 10
ans que nous consacrons au réseau
ferroviaire français et nous
augmenterons cet effort dès le PLF 2023
et nous attendons le Senna y contribue
d'ailleurs le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures pour
voir ensuite quels seront nos priorités
qui seront déclinées dans une
programmation actualisée dans les
prochains mois en même temps que nous
mettrons en place des contrats de plan
état région qui feront aussi une part
très significative au transport public
et au transport ferroviaire faut-il
regarder d'autres options travailler sur
l'offre travail abaisser les coûts de
l'énergie comme nous sommes en train de
le faire pour éviter qu'il y a des
difficultés en 2023 oui nous y
travaillons par le ciel comme ça que
nous éviterons des difficultés sur
l'offre dans les prochains mois et je
suis prêt à regarder avec le Sénat comme
tout le gouvernement
des leviers que nous pouvons activer sur
la base du rapport du coi dans les
prochains mois
quelques secondes je vous entends
monsieur le ministre il y a vraiment
urgence le président du Grand Est parle
d'être contraint peut-être de faire mes
lignes on envisage ici ou là des hausses
de tarifs donc monsieur le ministre
agissait vite et fort pour contrer ses
replis face à la crise merci
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre-Jean vierzolaine pour le groupe
Les Indépendants République et
territoire vous avez la parole
madame la ministre les Causses sont
multiples déjà la guerre déclenchée par
Poutine et ses conséquences sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz ensuite le
manque d'anticipation et d'entretien du
parc nucléaire qui fait à quelle heure
où nous parlons près de la moitié des
réacteurs ne fonctionnent pas et enfin
un système de fixation du prix européen
complètement dépassé résultat des
courses le prix de l'électricité n'est
plus maîtrisé les ménages sont pour le
moment plus ou moins protégés par le
bouclier tarifaire les commerçants les
usines les entreprises totalement
exposées il y a deux jours je voyais
encore un boulanger qui avait payé l'an
dernier 2500 euros de factures
électriques on lui propose pour l'année
prochaine remis le 23 des contrats qui
approchent 20.000 euros juste intenable
les collectivités pas de visibilité
budgétaire
qui va peser évidemment sur les
investissements et sur les capacités à
assurer les services du quotidien il
existe des dispositifs de soutien trop
restrictifs et trop complexe il y a la
réponse de fond quel mix énergétique
pour quelle indépendance mais là
maintenant tout de suite dans les jours
qui viennent nous avons besoin d'une
réponse coordonnée à l'échelle
européenne et on peut dire que ça ne
démarre pas très bien un plan d'aide de
200 milliards mis en place par
l'Allemagne qui est nature à créer une
concurrence déloyale un sommet européen
la semaine dernière qui n'a pas apporté
les réponses attendues et un conseil des
ministres franco-allemand qui s'est
transformé en a déjeuné à l'isée
le temps presse les entreprises les
collectivités doivent renouveler leur
contrat avant le 31 décembre et elle
s'interroge sur le thème je dois signer
ou pas signer la proposition de mon
fournisseur d'énergie madame la ministre
pouvez nous dire où en sont les
négociations avec nos partenaires
européens et les mesures envisagées
merci pour vos réponses
de la transition
énergétique madame panier runacher vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur verse laine
vous soulignez à juste titre l'action du
gouvernement pour protéger les ménages
mais également les petites entreprises
de moins de 10 salariés et les petites
collectivités locales parce que je veux
rappeler ici que le dispositif de
bouclier énergétique que nous avons mis
en place il couvre les petites
entreprises et les petites collectivités
locales et il permet à ces petites
entreprises à ces petites collectivités
locales de bénéficier du prix de
l'électricité le plus bas d'Europe alors
vous avez raison il faut aller plus loin
il faut aller maintenant travailler pour
nos ETI nos grandes entreprises et faire
en sorte de trouver un dispositif et les
autres collectivités locales qui ne sont
pas couvertes mais vous savez que des
premières propositions ont été faites
avec un filet de sécurité pour amortir
le choc de cette augmentation du pré
l'électricité pour ce faire nous
agissons au niveau européen vous avez
mentionné monsieur le sénateur le
Conseil européen ce Conseil européen il
est arrivé à un cursus de 27 pays sur
des mesures très claires de coordination
sur le prix du gaz pour demander à la
Commission de faire des propositions sur
ce prix du gaz qui permettent
d'installer un corridor et de contenir
le prix du gaz sur le prix de
l'électricité avec un découplage du prix
du gaz et du prix électrique sur une
plateforme d'achat commune du gaz et sur
des mesures techniques je dirais mais
très importantes pour permettre de faire
des coupes circuits sur le marché et
marchés financier d'échanges
d'électricité et de gaz c'est une
avancée majeure et c'est le président de
la République qui les a obtenues d'autre
part au plan national et vous le savez
nous travaillons avec Bruno Le Maire
avec Christophe Béchu à mettre en place
également une garantie électricité et
des aides qui soient
que pour les PME nous avons a priori un
dispositif qui devrait les protéger
partiellement et nous finalisons ces
travaux vous savez que pour les ETI et
les grandes entreprises Bruno Le Maire
négocié actuellement une augmentation
des aides du cadre Ukraine et un
relâchement des conditions pour en
bénéficier donc nous sommes au travail
avec 10 milliards d'euros dans le cadre
de notre trajectoire budgétaire pour
faciliter et la vie de ces entreprises
merci la parole est
la parole est maintenant au président
Roger carochi pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux le gouvernement a finalement
changé de politique et décider de
rapatrier collectivement toutes les
femmes et les enfants de djihadistes
tenus en Syrie pourquoi
pour vos réponses la parole est au garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
[Applaudissements]
sur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le Président
caoutchi je serai tenté par un parce que
mais
je comprends parfaitement je comprends
parfaitement qu'il ne vous conviendrait
pas en réalité nous n'avons rien changé
nous rapatrions d'abord chaque fois que
c'est possible en terme de sécurité pour
nos agents et qui bien sûr je veux
rendre hommage
deuxièmement
notre doctrine n'a pas bougé d'un
millimètre il faut que les femmes
demandent leur rapatriement
troisièmement c'est une judiciarisation
systématique et je tiens à vous indiquer
que toutes les femmes ont fait l'objet
d'un mandat de dépôt sauf une pour des
raisons médicales et puis il y a le
problème des enfants
au fond s'agissant des femmes de la
judiciarisation elles ont choisi de nous
combattre là où elles sont allées c'est
un acte volontaire qui mérite que nous
judiciarisations et que nous
judiciarisions pardon et que nous
fassions avec toute la sévérité requise
mais il y a également les enfants il y a
un devoir d'humanité et de vigilance
humanité parce que ce sont des enfants
qu'ils n'ont rien demandé que ce sont
des enfants français que comme le dit
certains pédopsychiatres ce sont des
bombes à retardement qu'il faut veiller
sur eux mais qu'il faut que nous le
fassions parce que les laisser là-bas
c'est prendre le risque qu'un jour ils
reviennent ici pour commettre des
abominations et puis devoir évidemment
de vigilance dans un suivi qui est
pluridisciplinaire psychologique
psychiatrique éducatif je ne pense pas
que nous ayons bougé d'un millimètre et
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours de cela
je me suis complètement exprimé devant
la commission des Lois du Sénat et
monsieur le Président buffet a dit de
mon intervention j'en Rosie encore
qu'elle était claire et précise et si
vous souhaitez davantage de
renseignements je vous suggère ce
président caoutchi va les lire mon
intervention
sur le président carochi
monsieur le ministre
les femmes qui demandent à revenir elle
le font parce que nous ne les avons pas
déçus de la nationalité française ce que
le Royaume-Uni ce que le Royaume-Uni a
fait à l'égard des djihadistes ce qui
lui permet de ne pas récupérer les gens
retenus en Syrie je me permets de vous
rappeler également que lorsque Nicole
Belloubet était gardé sauts en 2019-2020
elle nous disait ici un la France
préfère qu'il y ait des jugements en
Irak avec des tribunaux mixtes et
ensuite elle nous a dit puisque ça n'est
pas faisable dans tous les cas nous
ferons du cas par cas et nous ne ferons
revenir en France que des gens dont nous
serons qu'il n'y a aucune dangerosité je
vous rappelle que c'était Donald Trump
merci Laurent merci le président Laurent
je vous rappelle que le c'est Donald
Trump qui avait demandé à la France et à
l'Europe de rapatrier ces épouses de
djihadistes et le président Macron à
l'époque avait été répondu pas question
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux pour la
sécurité des Français en quoi la
sécurité des Français en 2022 et
différentes de celle de 2019 surtout
monsieur le garder sceau et vous le
savez et c'est bien que la justice
s'occupe des femmes qui reviennent mais
la plupart d'entre elles la plupart
d'entre elles on continuait dans les
camps de détention en Syrie sur les
réseaux sociaux à vanter les mérites de
daesh inventer les mairies des attentats
et du fait de pouvoir continuer la lutte
des djihadistes en France et ailleurs
voilà qui nous avons fait rentrer
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
pour commencer permettez-moi de saluer
la mémoire des gendarmes récemment
décédés d'adresser une pensée aux
familles et à leurs collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition énergétique le groupe
Imerys a annoncé la mise en exploitation
minière d'ici 2027 d'un gisement de
lithium dans l'Allier qui sera l'un des
plus grands d'Europe ce qui est une
bonne chose
en effet le lithium connaît un essor
considérable car indispensable à la
révolution numérique et à la transition
écologique il est notamment nécessaire
aux batteries des véhicules électriques
on estime aujourd'hui une augmentation
des besoins en lithium de 42% d'ici 2040
et certains experts craignent une
pénurie d'ici 2030 il s'agit d'une bonne
nouvelle stratégique d'abord pour notre
souveraineté énergétique puisque nous
dépendons aujourd'hui entièrement de la
Chine pour nous approvisionner en
lithium l'annonce du groupe Imerys
permet d'affirmer à nouveau que notre
pays l'Union européenne ont enfin besoin
de mener une politique minière
ambitieuse et responsable le projet
émilie est également une bonne nouvelle
écologique car il n'y aura pas de
décarbonation sans électrification enfin
autre intérêt du projet économique cette
fois-ci puisqu’il mérite évoque la
création de 1000 emplois direct et
indirecte dans la région
cependant il ne s'agit pas d'un projet
neutre je souhaite attirer votre
attention et vous questionner sur la
gestion des risques sociétaux et
environnementaux qui accompagnent cette
exploitation la consommation d'énergie
les rejettes toxiques notamment sont
fréquemment pointés du doigt d'après
Imerys 7000 sera exemplaire sur le plan
écologique et respectera le standard
international Irma pour pallier à ces
incidences bien sûr encore une fois
c'est une bonne chose l'acceptabilité
sociale de ce genre de projet n'est pas
sous-estimer là où sont annoncés les
projets d'extraction des collectifs se
constituent aussi il y a nécessité à
rassurer l'opinion publique en
instaurant d'énormes respectueuses dans
notre environnement mais question sont
les suivantes comment le gouvernement
compte-t-il accompagner le respect de
ces engagements et l'acceptabilité
l'acceptabilité pardon local du projet
la mine durable va-t-elle enfin voir le
jour en France merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à madame la ministre de la
transition énergétique madame bannir une
hachée
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice gaker merci d'abord de
souligner combien ce projet participe
d'une politique de transition
énergétique qui anticipe qui cherche à
ne pas remplacer une dépendance aux
énergies fossiles par une dépendance à
d'autres matières premières critiques
comme le lithium le nickel et le cobalt
et vous le savez ce projet d'immery s'il
s'inscrit dans le plan France 2030 et il
fait partie des cinq projets que nous
soutenons pour justement recréer une
chaîne de valeur autour de ces métaux
critiques qui seront absolument
nécessaires pour la production de
batterie électrique et vous savez
combien ça compte notamment sur notre
territoire commun du Pas-de-Calais et
plus largement des Hauts de France
puisque nous accueillons la vallée
européenne de la batterie électrique et
nous aurons besoin de ces matières
premières alors pour aller plus loin
dans le cadre européen et dans le cadre
national cela fait maintenant plus de 18
mois que nous travaillons à créer une
filière
responsable autour de ces métaux
critiques autour de trois actions
sécurisées des approvisionnements à
l'étranger qui soient des
approvisionnements dans des mines
responsables et qui appliquent ce
référentiel de mines responsable qui est
notamment portée au niveau de la
Commission européenne par le
vice-président sfovich deuxièmement
mettre en place toutes les actions de
recyclage et ça fait partie des projets
que nous soutenons au niveau de France
2030 pour faire en sorte que toutes les
matières qui rentrent sur le territoire
français d'une manière ou d'une autre
puissent être réutilisée justement ne
pas avoir à devoir rechercher dans nos
sous-sols des matières premières
critiques et troisième élément en
responsabilité regarder la faisabilité
de développement de 2000 mais sur un
registre de mine responsable partager au
niveau européen il y a des cas de mines
responsables je pense à celle du
tungstène en Autriche qui avait été
d'ailleurs présenter lors du Conseil
Compétitivité à Lens que j'avais
organisé autour de cette notion qui est
au milieu d'un parc naturel et qui
montre que l'on peut agir dans ce sens
nous agirons donc dans ce sens en
responsabilité au niveau européen et au
niveau national merci
l'apparence est à notre collègue
Laurence Cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste merci
monsieur
[Musique]
et majeur de notre système de santé qui
est à bout de souffle des urgences au
service pédiatriques en passant par la
neurologie la psychiatrie tous les
voyants sont au rouge à l'hôpital public
sur l'ensemble du territoire personnel
épuisé soignants qui partent petit à
petit dégoûtée par leurs conditions de
travail dégradées depuis de longs mois
4000 professionnels en pédiatrie
viennent de lancer un appel au président
de la République dénonçant les
conditions désastreuses de prise en
charge des enfants transfert multiples
affectation dans des services adultes
non appropriés sortie trop précoce des
programmations d'opérations mises en
danger de petits patients ce n'est pas
la faute de la bronchiolite mais bien de
la politique menée depuis des années
dans les hôpitaux à coups de
restrictions budgétaire successives et
irresponsable des cris d'alarmes sont
lancées régulièrement par des
professionnels notre groupe les relais
ici dans l'hémicycle vous les ignorez
comme tous vos prédécesseurs face à
l'urgence de la situation et la
mobilisation des professionnels vous
avez dû annoncer le déblocage de 150
millions le blanc et des Assises de la
pédiatrie au printemps cela n'a
convaincu personne dans la crise est
grave et structurelle allez-vous enfin
entendre l'appel de ces professionnels
qui parlent de perte de sens dans leur
métier conséquences de la gouvernance
bureaucratique et de la tarification à
l'activité allez-vous comme il vous le
demande ouvrir des lits dans les
services de pédiatrie en arrêtant la
fuite des soignants et en recrutant des
jeunes qui sont passionnés
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur Braun vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs mesdames la
sénatrice Cohen j'imagine bien sûr que
je suis très près le problème de notre
hôpital public je le suis
depuis plusieurs semaines en étant en
contact d'ailleurs avec les
professionnels de la pédiatrie que j'ai
rencontré à plusieurs reprises je ne
suis depuis que je suis arrivé au
ministère et pour être honnête je le
suis même depuis de nombreuses années
pour suivre ces difficultés alors vous
avez annoncé un certain nombre de choses
que l'hôpital n'allait pas bien depuis
plusieurs mois permettez-moi de vous
dire que l'hôpital ne va pas bien depuis
plusieurs années plusieurs dizaines
d'années grâce ou à cause de politique
comptable je vous rejoins dont un
certain nombre ont été votés par
l'ensemble du Parlement depuis
malheureusement trop longtemps en ce qui
concerne l'engagement de ce gouvernement
en ce qui concerne l'engagement depuis
2017 du président de la République ce
sont 53 milliards d'euros qui ont été
mis en plus dans l'hôpital pour répondre
certes à des problèmes conjoncturels
mais également des problèmes structurels
à vous parler de de la pédiatrie des
problèmes de bronchiolite de quoi
parle-t-on nous parlons effectivement
d'une épidémie de bronchiolite qui
survient plutôt qu'avant sur un hôpital
qui est vous l'avez dit vous-même à bout
de souffle mais j'irai là aussi dans le
dans le même sens je tiens d'ailleurs au
passage mes anciens collègues allaient
soignants dans tous les services qui
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles en ce qui concerne la
bronchiolite qui est une pathologie qui
est inquiétante qui fait peur et je
comprends l'inquiétude des parents je
vais aussi rappeler qu'elle est très
majoritairement bénigne et doit être
pris en charge en priorité par les
médecins généralistes alors les réponses
qu'apportent sont gouvernement et sous
l'impulsion de la première ministre des
réponses structurelles avec un budget de
150 millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
émis pour répondre aux problèmes aigus
d'un certain nombre de services ces
services de pédiatrie bien entendu en
premier recours et j'en profite pour
rappeler que ce ne sont pas uniquement
les urgences pédiatriques mais plus au
niveau des services de pédiatrie et puis
une réponse plus structurelle sur
l'ensemble du système hospitalier en ce
qui concerne la pédiatrie nous débutons
dès la semaine prochaine des travaux
pour aboutir au printemps et je l'ai
annoncé à des Assises de la pédiatrie
qui nous permettront de prendre des
vraies décisions structurelles sur ce
secteur merci
mais le diagnostic il est connu c'est
l'ordonnance qui est mauvaise la
prescription vous nous dites que vous
accordez des millions supplémentaires
mais les professionnels vous demandent à
grand renfort de de d'appel qu'il faut
absolument embaucher et que vos
solutions ne sont pas bonnes nous
n'avons pas voté les budgets
austéritaires nous au niveau de notre
groupe et qui mettent à genoux l'hôpital
quand allez-vous réhausser réellement
l'ont d'âme à la hauteur de l'inflation
vous ne le faites même pas pour 2023
vous n'écoutez pas les professionnels
vous n'écoutez pas les parlementaires et
vous dites tout va bien ça va très mal
et il faut que vous agissiez en urgence
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de pire que de trier
des patients de choisir entre deux
enfants la responsabilité elle est pas
du côté des professionnels de santé elle
est du côté du gouvernement et vous
pouvez hausser la tête nous rencontrons
les professionnels ils sont très en
colère contre vous agissez
la parole est à notre collègue Julien
barjoton pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant
monsieur le Président merci ma question
s'adresse à Madame le Ministre de la
Culture madame la ministre
la
baisse du de fréquentation des salles de
cinéma d'environ - 25 % par rapport à
2019 inquiète les professionnels du
secteur d'autres évolutions comme la
consommation des films ou des séries sur
les plateformes à domicile les inquiets
également si le cinéma français doit
certainement se réinventer il s'agit
d'un système que nous devons préserver
Simone les harkis novembre un beau matin
l'innocent la rentrée montre la vitalité
la diversité et la singularité du cinéma
français son système repose sur la
mutualisation les films à succès
finançant les films plus fragiles
n'oublions pas que le cinéma d'auteur
est né en France dans les années 50 en
réaction au cinéma américain plus
industriel
qui faisait appel aux têtes d'affiche
n'oublions pas non plus que les films
dit du milieu qui font aussi la
spécificité du cinéma en France souffre
beaucoup
la photographie c'est la vérité et le
cinéma c'est la vérité 24 fois par
seconde disait Jean-Luc golard mais pour
que cette vérité émerge il faut le choix
d'une mise en scène il faut un chef
opérateur ou une chef opérateur il faut
des comédiennes des comédiens des
dialogues écrits ou des silences des
ellipses il faut de la qualité madame la
ministre
quelle appréciation portez-vous sur les
évolutions en cours structurelles ou
bien conjoncturel quelle perspective
pouvez-vous donner aux professionnels
pour redonner l'envie aux Français de
rejoindre les seuls obscures et pour
garantir le financement de notre système
unique merci beaucoup
on va répondre la parole de tabadables
la ministre de la Culture madame Abdoul
Malak
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Julien barjetton mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de nous
donner l'occasion de parler du cinéma en
ce jour où nous lançons une campagne de
communication pour soutenir les salles
on a tous une bonne raison d'aller au
cinéma je suis sûr que tous ici sur ces
bancs vous aurez votre bonne raison
d'aller au cinéma c'est une campagne
pour mobiliser nos citoyens pendant un
mois c'est une campagne pour recréer du
désir d'aller en salle voir les films en
grand et au-delà de cette campagne de
court terme à plus long terme je suis
persuadée que nous avons tous de bonnes
raisons de croire en l'avenir du cinéma
pourquoi parce que d'abord la France
reste une nation de cinéphile certes
nous avons perdu un quart de public par
rapport à l'avant covid mais c'est bien
pire ailleurs moi 60% de fréquentation
en Italie moins 50% en Corée du Sud - 40
% en Espagne ou en Allemagne donc notre
filière résiste et les Français restent
cinéphiles
par ailleurs l'État accompagne un élan
nouveau celui de la jeunesse avec le
Pass Culture 2 millions et demi de place
de cinéma sont partis financés par
l'État pour inciter les jeunes à aller
au cinéma 76% des jeunes interrogés
disent aller plus au cinéma grâce au
Pass Culture la filière aussi grâce à
elle elle se réinvente vous l'avez dit
elle reste très mobilisée dans les
années 80-90 on nous prédisait la mort
du cinéma à cause de l'avènement de la
télévision la fréquentation avait chuté
à 110 millions de spectateurs et ça a
doublé dans les années qui suivaient
parce que la filière s'est réinventée
parce que l'État était aussi à leur côté
et je le précise le soutien de l'État
n'a jamais été aussi fort il y a un
arsenal de soutien pour soutenir cette
filière du cinéma qui est unique au
monde 300 millions déployés pendant la
crise sanitaire 500 millions le budget
du CNC annuel pour le cinéma 100
millions de crédits d'impôt pour le
cinéma et le plan France 2030 qui nous
permet d'employer 350 millions gros
aussi pour la filière et je le dis à la
jeunesse il y a énormément de bons films
à voir pendant les vacances de la
Toussaint vous qui êtes en tribune en
famille venez allez au cinéma beaucoup
d'émotions vous attendent
merci
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président
11000 c'est le nombre de TER supprimés
dans les hauts de France depuis le 1er
janvier 2022
129 c'est le nombre de trains supprimés
retirés dans les hauts de France pendant
les vacances de la Toussaint au prétexte
que les élèves ne prenant pas le train
on peut retirer 129 train 3h30 c'est le
temps qu'on passait à la gare du Nord la
semaine dernière des usagers jusqu'à
11h30 du soir pour s'entasser ensuite
dans le dernier train je vous parle des
Hauts-de-France je vous parle des trains
supprimés vous êtes supprimé c'est la
malédiction qui tombe sur les voyageurs
quand ils arrivent dans les gares que ce
soit la gare du Nord à Beauvais à Lens à
Saint-Quentin partout je vous parle des
Hauts de France parce que c'est ma
région je pourrais vous parler tout
aussi bien toutes les régions de France
y compris l'Île-de-France
monsieur le ministre les usagers
quotidiens du train sont des salariés
des gens qui prennent le métro le train
le RER pour se rendre de leur lieu de
travail à leur domicile et c'est
salariés ils prennent le train parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se loger là où ils
travaillent ou alors ils ne peuvent pas
travailler là où ils vivent ils ont
accepté des emplois ou des logements
loin l'un de l'autre parce qu'il y avait
des transports collectifs c'est
essentiel dans leur mode de vie c'est ce
qui structure et qui détermine leur
organisation de vie et l'imprévisibilité
des transports publics désorganisent
totalement leur vie c'est
imprévisibilité elle met le rond-point
en danger elle insécurisée par an qui ne
savent jamais à quelle heure ils
pourront aller chercher leurs enfants à
l'école et je ne pensais toute
particulière pour ces femmes qui le
matin prennent le train à Creil ou le
soir pour faire les ménages dans les
bureaux les conséquences sont multiples
maltraitance des voyageurs reportent sur
la voiture émission de CO2 des
organisations du travail et française
monsieur le ministre il y a urgence que
faites-vous
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre délégués en charge des
transports monsieur Beaune
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente rossignols je partage d'abord
les mots que vous avez eus pour les
galères que vivent un certain nombre de
concitoyens dans la région des Hauts de
France mais aussi dans d'autres régions
face à des difficultés spécifiques dans
les transports publics la priorité que
j'ai décrite il y a encore quelques
minutes en réponse au sénateur fermé
qu'elle n'est pas théorique nous avons
augmenté les moyens cette année pour le
réseau et pour les transports du
quotidien maintenant pour répondre à une
situation difficile il faut nommer les
choses de manière précise et que chacun
assume ses responsabilités de quoi
parle-t-on le transport qui sont
régionaux et donc il y a une situation
spécifique haute France que je
discuterai à nouveau avec le président
Bertrand j'ai évoqué d'ailleurs le sujet
avec le président Rapin ici même au
Sénat il y a une semaine et il faut que
chacun soit prêt à mettre les moyens
nécessaires la région en particulier qui
est la responsabilité d'organiser les
trains express régionaux il faut le dire
l'état sera là en soutien pour un
certain nombre de projets nous le ferons
pour le réseau express métropolitain
j'ai échangé par exemple avec le
président Castelain de la métropole pour
que nous résolvions le problème la
livraison du train dans les prochains
mois donc nous agissons ce sur quoi nous
sommes responsables et je veux le dire
aussi du côté de la SNCF j'aurai une
réunion avec le PDG de la SNCF en fin de
semaine parce que les questions d'offres
qui relèvent sans doute de l'opérateur
et je veux que les tâches joues son rôle
à plein qu'est-ce qui se passe en
particulier dans la région des Hauts de
France car chaque situation est
spécifique nous devons y répondre
précisément il y a des pénuries de
recrutement et donc il y a des
difficultés les suppressions pour les
vacances que vous avez évoquées sont
beaucoup liées à ça et donc je ne me
résous pas ce que nous vivions dans
cette situation de cette manière pour
les mois qui viennent il faut accélérer
les recrutements la SNCF a lancé un plan
exceptionnel de 440 recrutement pour la
seule région des Hauts-de-France pour
les TER et donc en travaillant ensemble
avec la région avec ceux qui relèvent de
l'État avec l'opérateur SNCF nous
améliorons la situation les prochains
mois vous avez raison de dire que c'est
difficile mais il faut que chacun puisse
assumer ses responsabilités financières
d'organisation et de moyens merci je
vais donner maintenant la parole notre
collègue Maryse Carrère pour le groupe
du Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole ma chère
collègues merci merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur marcéno ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre les
Français se sont découverts depuis
quelques années un engouement croissant
pour le tourisme à montagne un
environnement au mode de vie si
particulier s'agissant de l'autre
versant celui de la vie montagnarde la
loi montagne a permis d'instaurer des
politiques adaptées à la vie en altitude
en matière d'agriculture la loi pose
ainsi un double principe celui général
de la préservation de l'activité contre
les préjudices causés par les actes de
prédation et celui de la régulation pour
maintenir l'existence de l'élevage si
des mesures ont été mises en place
notamment après la réintroduction de
l'ours dans les Pyrénées en 2018 et la
propagation du loup sur l'ensemble du
territoire le malaise des éleveurs
persistent tandis que les prédations
continuent l'été dernier le loup était à
peine
identifié dans le massif du otacam dans
les Hautes-Pyrénées quand relevait déjà
26 attaques pour 43 brevets tués malgré
la grande réactivité des services de
l'État que je salue et qui très tôt se
sont tenus aux côtés des éleveurs il en
est de même dans l'Hérault en Lozère
dans les Alpes-de-Haute-Provence et
d'entendre d'autres départements touchés
de plein fouet par la prédation du loup
aujourd'hui le problème des prédations
perdure malgré les demandes fortement
relayées du Sénat face à l'ampleur du
phénomène l'Association nationale des
élus de la montagne a adopté jeudi
dernier une émotion rappelant
l'obligation de défense de l'agro
pastoralisme et une meilleure gestion
des grands prédateurs ne l'oublions pas
l'agro pastoralisme est une activité
agricole d'excellence qui joue un rôle
de régulation de la végétation et
contribue au développement de l'activité
économique et touristique aussi Monsieur
le Ministre ma question sera simple
quelle mesure nouvelle comptez-vous
mettre en place afin de répondre à la
demande des éleveurs dont l'activité
pastorale continue d'être menacée nos
éleveurs sont aujourd'hui à bout ils
attendent des dispose des dispositions
et des décision ferme et efficace je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur Marc
fedo avait la parole merci merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carrère je voudrais vous
remercier de cette caisse de me poser
cette question qui pose la question de
l'équilibre entre un groupe pastoralisme
et nous en particulier j'étais comme
vous le savez en fin de semaine dans le
Doubs puis d'en savoir enfin dans les
deux sa voix pour évoquer en particulier
cette question qui est très prégnante
nul ne peut évoquer cette question et
vous avez raison de rappeler sans
souligner quand on est auprès des
éleveurs j'ai été rencontré un éleveur
qui venait d'être prédaté le sentiment
de détresse le sentiment d'impuissance
et le sentiment d'incompréhension qu'ils
ont de la prédation et de la menace que
ça fait peser sur deux sur eux deuxième
élément rappelez quand même que le
pastoralisme vous l'avez dit pour des
questions touristiques mais c'est un
modèle qui est un modèle exemplaire
aussi en termes de biodiversité il y a
besoin de préserver la biodiversité du
lot mais il y a aussi besoin de
préserver les autres formes de
biodiversité qui sont garanties par les
activités de pastoralisme
et d'agriculture extensive alors comment
nous pouvons agir d'abord le président
de la République l'a rappelé dans votre
département cet été l'idée c'est qu'au
niveau européen nous travaillons sur le
statut de l'espace l'espèce à partir de
données scientifiques deuxième élément
c'est que nous travaillons au niveau
national le président d'ailleurs à cette
occasion avait rappelé le développement
d'une deuxième brigade de loup pour
travailler sur ces questions de
prédation deuxième élément travail au
niveau national sur quoi on peut
travailler avec mon collègue Christophe
Béchu avec Bérengère Couillard nous
travaillons sur ce sujet dans le cadre
du plan national loup ou à l'extérieur
de travailler sur des modalités de
simplification simplification pour
effectuer les prélèvements réellement
simplification dans les procédures
d'indemnisation trop souvent
l'indemnisation ne tient pas compte de
l'ensemble du préjudice qui est porté on
est que sur les animaux prédatés mais
pas ceux qui sont perdus ou la perte
génétique et ça c'est un élément qui est
important troisième élément travailler
sur un dénombrement qui fasse l'objet
d'un consensus puisque c'est à partir de
ce dénombrement que les prélèvements
sont effectués 19% de la population
recensée enfin dernier élément il faut
qu'on travaille aussi sur le statut du
Patou qui pose des tas de questions
juridiques pour les éleveurs évidemment
quand ils viennent mordre ici ou là un
touriste voilà madame la sénatrice on
est bien sur un chemin que nous
entendons tracer avec mon collègue bechy
et ma collègue Couillard pour avancer
concrètement et donner des moyens pour
avancer pour qu'on préserve l'agro
pastoralisme on doit aux éleveurs et on
doit à la biodiversité mais à toute la
biodiversité merci merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est
à notre collègue Jean Raymond Hugonnet
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la Culture depuis le 2 septembre
dernier le groupe Canal+ a cessé de
diffuser les cinq chaînes du groupe TF1
à la suite d'un différents commercial
concernant le renouvellement du contrat
de leur distribution
la justice a eu l'occasion de se
prononcer à deux reprises sur ce
différent qui pénalisent tout
particulièrement les foyers situés en
zone rurale et en zone de montagne et
qui reçoivent la télévision numérique
par satellite en considérant que la loi
ne crée aucune obligation à la charge de
Canal+ de reprise des chaînes de la TNT
et que aucun contrat écrit signé avec le
groupe TF1 n'obligeait Canal+ à mettre à
disposition ces chaînes la cour d'appel
de Paris a certes clarifié la situation
du point de vue du droit mais elle n'a
pas résolu les difficultés rencontrées
par des millions de Français
le gouvernement est resté très discret
depuis deux mois sur cette situation
tandis que l'arcome qui a proposé
plusieurs fois sa médiation estime
qu'elle n'a pas les moyens juridiques
d'imposer un compromis dans ces
conditions que comptez-vous faire madame
la ministre pour permettre aux Français
qui ont aujourd'hui privés d'accéder à
la TNT
pour vous répondre la parole de ta
madame la ministre de la Culture madame
la ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Hugonnet je partage vos
préoccupations
vous l'avez dit cette situation résulte
dans différents commercial du
négociation commerciale qui n'aboutit
pas
il ne m'appartient pas de m'immiscer
dans cette négociation commerciale mais
en tant que ministre de la Culture je
suis évidemment très attentive à l'accès
de tous à l'offre gratuite de la TNT
j'ai dès le début de ce conflit écrit au
président du groupe Canal+ pour en
appeler à son sens des responsabilités
de l'intérêt général pour éviter de
priver des foyers des de millions de
Français de l'accès aux cinq chaînes du
groupe TF1 pour l'instant cette
négociation n'a pas encore abouti et
effectivement vous avez rappelé les
décisions de justice Vous avez rappelé
les déclarations de l'arcome une
modification de la loi sera probablement
à l'avenir nécessaire pour éviter que
cela se reproduise et que des
téléspectateurs soient pris en otage de
ce type de négociation nous y
travaillerons ensemble je l'espère en
tout cas à court terme je sais que les
discussions ont repris nouveau patron
qui est arrivé aussi à la tête de TF1
Rodolphe belle-mère avec Canal+ espérons
collectivement qu'il parviendront à un
accord qui permettra de rétablir au plus
vite l'accès aux chaînes tout de suite
de la TNT
en l'occurrence vous nous appelez à
l'espoir il ne s'agit pas d'espoir la
réalité est simple la loi de 1986 qui a
été modifié cher collègue plus de 80
fois depuis 86 et qui sous-tend
l'écosystème de l'audiovisuel est
aujourd'hui à genoux
cette loi votre collègue francriester
que je vois ici au banc également avec
commencé à porter une réforme très
rapidement elle a été abandonnée
aujourd'hui elle a été abandonnée en
rase campagne pour des raisons de covid
qui étaient simples à l'époque à mettre
en avant la raison est ici au Sénat nous
sommes prêts à travailler sur cette loi
de 86 revisitée parce qu'il faut se
mettre aujourd'hui à jour des
plateformes numériques et des usages des
chaînes de télévision notamment nous
vous appelons à ce chantier chir madame
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Marc
Destiny pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
les chers collègues madame la ministre
pendant que les médias français étaient
occupés par le feuilleton du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale tomber les
conclusions du sommet européen qui était
à la limite de la débâcle pour la France
et qui consacrait l'échec de 50
politiques européennes françaises projet
phare du président de la République les
Allemands une partie des pays européens
ont fait prévaloir leur point de vue
tant au prix du Taz et nous renvoie nous
les Français à nos problèmes de
maintenance de nos centrales nucléaires
l'accord de principe sur un bout de
ligne anti-missile entre plusieurs pays
européens autour de l'Allemagne sans la
France ceux dans l'OTAN s'est félicités
nous laisse je dirais isoler sur le
concept d'une Europe de la défense
malgré le conflit en Ukraine
sur le spatial l'Allemagne s'oppose au
principe de préférence européenne et
développe seul en mer du Nord des
projets de port spatiale dédiée au micro
lanceur force est constatée le recul de
notre influence en Europe et en même
temps la France se voit reprocher une
certaine arrogance les dissensions dans
le couple franco-allemand sont tellement
importants qu'il a fallu pour la
troisième fois reporter le sommet
franco-allemand qui devait se lire
aujourd'hui à Fontainebleau ces
multiples alertes doivent être entendus
l'Allemagne depuis le brexit est au
centre du jeu européen et regardent
désormais plus à l'est et vers les
Balkans que vers Paris
elle défend ses intérêts elle s'affirme
comme leader de l'Union européenne où
les pays du Nord lui sont acquis depuis
longtemps alors madame la ministre
quelle leçon tire la France de cette
situation pour nous éviter un isolement
sur le plan international et en
particulier au sein de l'Union
européenne
pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'Europe de Laurence
Gaud madame la ministre avait la parole
[Musique]
écoutez nous n'avons absolument pas la
même vision des choses
je vais commencer par vous rappeler que
nous avons tous des enjeux communs dus à
la guerre en Ukraine qui porte sur
l'énergie qui porte sur la défense et
qui vont ensuite porter évidemment sur
d'autres domaines économiques y compris
le spatial
ces enjeux communs ils se reflète aussi
avec le changement géostratégique vous
avez vu la position de la Chine et
comment elle évolue tous les pays font
face à ces enjeux mais pas de la même
façon quand c'était la crise du covid
c'était les économies de services qui
étaient les plus affectés aujourd'hui
quand c'est l'énergie ce sont les
économies manufacturières et l'Allemagne
fait face à des conditions très
difficiles
d'énergie de fournitures puisqu'il faut
qu'elle en trouve ailleurs qu'en Russie
mais également de prix
face à ces enjeux qu'est-ce que nous
faisons le président de la République
pendant le Conseil européen a invité le
président Scholt Saidi à discuté ensuite
c'est lui monsieur qui a réussi à
unifier les positions pour que nous
ayons un communiqué à la fin du conseil
qui étudie absolument toutes les mesures
énergétiques qui peuvent être
spécifiques à chaque pays enfin
aujourd'hui ces problèmes cette défense
d'énergie de réorganisation du monde ils
vont pas se résoudre un claquement de
main et c'est pourquoi le président a
invité le chancelier Scholt sa venir
déjeuner et d'ici au 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée nous allons travailler ensemble
pour pouvoir converger sur tous ces
sujets mais voyez-vous ce sont des
efforts qui demandent plus que des
paroles des actions et du travail je
vous remercie
madame la ministre difficile pour vous
de répondre je dirais que tout va très
bien Madame le marquise mais je vous
rappellerai le discours du président de
la République qu'il avait prononcé sur
l'Europe à la Sorbonne je pense qu'il
faudrait le relire lorsque vous dites
que tout se passe autour d'un déjeuner
on regarde un peu ce que ce qui se passe
en France tous les médias disent
clairement qu'il y a que dans les
discours français qu'on parle du couple
franco-allemand pour le reste
l'Allemagne mène le jeu elle mène le bal
et puis au niveau de la réflexion
française sur l'Union européenne le
président de la République avait utilisé
pour l'OTAN le terme dans ce phalogramme
plat j'ai peur qu'aujourd'hui on soyons
nous réduits à nos affaires dans le
développement de l'Europe
la parole
est à notre collègue Max Brisson pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président depuis
Aristide Briand la religion ne peut
faire obstacle à la loi et la République
a peu à peu donner à la laïcité une
dimension singulière dans l'enceinte de
nos écoles pourtant le mois dernier tout
comme au public les chiffres du chômage
Vous annoncez monsieur le ministre
l'éducation nationale 313 atteinte à la
laïcité et Monsieur le Ministre 313
atteintes à laïcité se sont en réalité
313 violations de la loi à défaut de
nous rassurer vous affirmez n'avoir pas
la main qui tremble vous appelez que les
équipes pour rappeler que les équipes
valeurs de la République ont été
renforcés tout comme la formation des
professeurs enfin vous annoncez un plan
de communication sur les réseaux sociaux
pour réduire l'action des influenceurs
ne pensez-vous pas plutôt face à un
projet politique radical celui de
l'islamisme qu'il faille d'abord
appliquer la loi dans toute sa rigueur
la semaine dernière proviseur parisien
disait dans une interview un collégien
qui fume on le sanctionne des élèves qui
portent des tenues religieuses c'est
plus compliqué on monte de cadre précis
alors Monsieur le Ministre ma question
est simple quand allez-vous donner à
tous les chefs d'établissement de France
un cadre précis des instructions
précises que pour que face à ces
violations de la loi isaient la
certitude d'avoir le soutien de leur
hiérarchie pour appliquer la loi toute
la loi règle la loi merci
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Brisson en la
matière vous avez raison la boussole
c'est la loi de 2004 et j'ai bien
indiqué qu'il fallait une application
ferme stricte de la loi de 2004 vous
avez rappelé le renforcement des équipes
valeurs de la République nous parlons
ici de plusieurs centaines de personnes
à l'échelle du territoire nous les
renforçons encore cet automne la
formation vous l'avez rappelé des
sanctions ont été prises contre des
élèves récalcitrants elles seront encore
prises au terme des procédures engagées
nous allons d'ailleurs vérifier et
également relancer et préciser les
choses en matière de sanction qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à l'exclusion
définitive des élèves concernés et en
effet des sanctions de cette nature ont
été prises vous avez également mentionné
la question des réseaux sociaux c'est
une question juridiquement délicate d'un
point de vue pour s'attaquer directement
à ces comptes et à ses influenceurs
néfastes qui ne veulent ni de bien aux
élèves ni de bien à l'école ni de bien à
la République mais nous sommes très
actifs là-dessus et je vais recevoir un
certain nombre de dirigeants de ces
réseaux sociaux pour les mettre devant
les responsabilités nous sommes et nous
serons très actifs et très vigilants sur
cette question enfin la laïcité c'est
une question aussi de sanctions j'en ai
parlé et vous avez mentionné en effet ce
que j'ai dit je n'ai pas et je n'aurais
pas la main qui tremble là-dessus mais
c'est aussi une question de pédagogie
nous avons une bataille à mener et à
mener de nouveau pour faire bien
comprendre que la laïcité est une
liberté la possibilité de transmission
de savoir qui se fasse sans interférence
la garantie de l'émancipation et de
l'éducation des futurs citoyens de la
République merci
monsieur Brisson monsieur le ministre je
crée que vous ne répondiez pas au chef
d'établissement il se sentent seuls ils
ne veulent pas avoir arbitrer ils
veulent des consignes claires pour ne
pas avoir à interpréter ne les laissez
pas seul votre collègue Gérald Darmanin
parle d'une offensive islamiste visant
les plus jeunes elle passe par l'école
alors Monsieur le Ministre précisez le
cadre donner des instructions au siège
d'établissements soutenez vos chefs
d'établissements pour que désormais il
sera assuré que toute violation de la
loi soit sanctionnée merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Catherine Morin du saillie pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
question concerne plusieurs ministères
mais s'adresse à madame la ministre de
la Culture qui a tutelle sur les
collections publiques en juillet 2020
pour célébrer le 58e anniversaire de
l'indépendance de l'Algérie la France a
restitué à Alger 24 crânes détenus au
Musée de l'Homme supposé être ceux de
chefs de la Résistance tuée pendant la
conquête coloniale or une enquête du New
York Times vient de révéler que la
majorité des crânes ne serait pas ceux
de résistants mais non identifié ou
d'origine incertaine certains parlent
d'imbroglio de procédures imparfaites
d'autres de scandales d'État il semble
que le travail du comité d'experts
scientifique franco-algérien qui œuvrait
depuis 2018 à l'identification des
crânes condamnée à la plus stricte
confidentialité était courtée pourquoi
comment ce geste hautement symbolique de
réconciliation que nous ne côtestons
nullement sur le fond mais sur la forme
le gouvernement ayant décidé du seul
d'une convention de dépôt et non d'un
acte législatif de restitution tout en
en revendiquant l'appellation pourquoi
cela a été dénaturé madame la ministre
le Parlement garant des collections
nationale totalement contourner dans
cette affaire et je le regrette est en
droit d'obtenir des réponses
pour vous répondre la parole de Kev Adam
la ministre de la Culture merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci de votre engagement sur
ce sujet je sais que vous portez cet
engagement de longue date et c'est un
enjeu qui me tient très à coeur cette
politique de restitution c'est regarder
notre histoire en face c'est nouer des
relations de partenariat et d'amitié
nouvelles avec d'autres pays avec
d'autres peuples c'est un chemin subtil
respectueux qui qui a un chemin qui
n'est ni celui du déni ni celui de la
repentance qui est celui de la
reconnaissance je voulais vous apporter
quelques précisions sur le cas des
crânes Algériens qui ont été déposés et
non pas restituer en effet les autorités
françaises et algériennes ont mis en
place en décembre 2017
un comité mixte qui était chargé
d'identifier formellement ces restes
humains dans les réserves du Muséum
national d'histoire naturelle il y a eu
un travail d'études rigoureux qui a duré
18 mois la Commission est arrivée à la
conclusion que 24 crânes sur 45
remplissez toutes les conditions
pour être restitués mais c'est sur cette
base consensuelle et documentée qu'ils
ont été remis sur la forme d'un dépôt à
l'Algérie il n'a jamais été dit le
contraire
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie aussi au
communiqué final du Comité
intergouvernemental de haut niveau qui
précisait aussi ce terme de restes
humains présumé algériens conservés dans
les collections publiques françaises au
paragraphe 19
donc on avait pris toutes les
précautions nécessaires sur ce sujet
au-delà de ce cas spécifique et nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler nous
allons travailler ensemble à des lois
cadres pour poser une doctrine une
méthode des critères de restituabilité
pour qu'à l'avenir sur différentes
catégories de sujets que ce soit les
restes humains que ce soit les biens
poliers juifs un cas très différents ou
que ce soit les biens pillés pendant la
colonisation en Afrique ou pris de façon
illégale ou illégitime nous aurons de
riches débats pour définir ces critères
et une orientation qui pourrait être
celle d'une loi cadre sur chacun de ces
trois sujets je vous remercie
la morale de saillie
je me réjouis enfin de ce travail
partagé le Sénat comme vous le savez
engagé les travaux très importants avec
mes collègues pierre ouzulia base
Brisson et plusieurs autres collègues et
le soutien de notre président de
commission Laurent Lafont nous avons
d'ores et déjà formulé des propositions
et un texte de loi voté à la illimité en
janvier dernier sur la question des
restes humains distinctibles ce texte
aurait été complètement voté il aurait
résolu complètement la question de
restitution des crânes à l'Algérie au
demeurant je voulais signer madame la
minisque malgré tout vous défendez
l'indéfendable car j'ai les conclusions
là de la commission qui s'est réunit le
25 juin 2020 chargé d'examiner les
propositions de restitution de ces
restes humains d'origine algérienne et
qu'elles sont quand même les conclusions
de la commission elle dit bien à la
commission alerte sur le risque de
protestation sur le caractère précipité
et autoritaire de l'opération la
commission note que les modalités
imposées par l'urgence diplomatique
interrompre le travail de mémoire
réalisé par le comité d'experts et j'en
parce qu'il y a d'autres remarques qui
soulignent aussi et c'est fort dommage
que le ministère de la Culture est
écarté comme le Parlement lightsé de
cette procédure je pense qu'il faut
remettre de l'ordre dans ce sujet pour
souligner l'importance du bien fondé de
la réconciliation des mémoires merci
la parole est à notre collègue Florence
Larade pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues se sont
actuellement 6500 soignants en pédiatrie
qui ont signé une lettre ouverte au
président de la République où il dit non
c'est les mises en danger quotidiennes
des patients dans des services saturés
on cause l'épidémie de bronchiolite et
des services hospitaliers très
fragilisés qui peinent à recruter et à
garder du personnel notamment par un
médical pourtant l'épidémie de
bronchiolite est habituelle à l'automne
et donc prévisible monsieur le ministre
cette situation n'est malheureusement
pas nouvelle en 2019 déjà faute de place
on réanimation des enfants ont dû être
transférés hors de la région
Île-de-France mais aujourd'hui ce
problème se pose avec acuité sur
l'ensemble du territoire et des enfants
sont régulièrement transférés d'un
hôpital à l'autre parfois même à plus de
200 km comment en est-on arrivé là les
capacités d'accueil des services se
dégradent en raison de la fermeture de
lit et de manque de personnel soignants
on manque de médecins libéraux on
restreint l'accès aux urgences et on ne
fait plus appel au kinés thérapeute pour
les bronchiolites pourtant d'après une
étude la plateforme akiraspille l'offre
de soins en kiné respiratoire permet de
réduire de 13% les consultations
pédiatriques au CHU de Bordeaux le
week-end toujours le même constat le
gouvernement n'a rien anticipé et gère
la pénurie avait des rustines le
déclenchement de plan blanc oblige à
déprogrammer des interventions
chirurgicales pour une simple épidémie
bronchiolite sans qu'il y ait
véritablement de perspective
d'amélioration
vous avez annoncé le déblocage de 150
millions d'euros pour les services en
tension à l'hôpital notamment en
pédiatrie mais Monsieur le Ministre
est-ce que le gouvernement envisage
enfin de mettre en oeuvre des mesures
structurelles en revalorisant
significativement la permanence des
soins de nuit du week-end des jours
fériés en augmentant le nombre de
pédiatres en libéral et à l'hôpital et
en acceptant qui est kiné puis à nouveau
intervenir pour lutter contre l'épidémie
de bronchiolite comme c'était le cas
auparavant
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
c'est le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
sénateurs madame la sénatrice la Sarrade
je vous remercie de reprendre cette
question sur le premier à la
bronchiolite et à nos hôpitaux vous
savez que ça me préoccupe
particulièrement mais je veux apporter
quelques précisions dans ce que je peux
entendre
non on ne trie pas les enfants à
l'entrée de l'hôpital les monts un sens
celui-ci c'est ajouter artificiellement
de l'inquiétude de l'angoisse aux
parents ça peut même être plus dangereux
que ça en poussant à du renoncement aux
soins donc je le redis avec force notre
système de santé prend en charge tous
les enfants en situation de détresse
système de santé dans son ensemble et il
le prend en charge dans des parcours de
soins
identifiés pour répondre aux besoins je
le redis toutes les bronchiolites ne
doivent pas aller à l'hôpital
quel parcours vous parlez de la place
des kinésithérapeutes il y a plusieurs
mois la Haute Autorité de Santé a
relever que certaines pratiques de
kinésithérapie habituelles faites sur la
bronchiolite sont dangereuses qu'il faut
les arrêter donc la place est maintenant
beaucoup moins importante des
kinésithérapeutes dans cette pathologie
précise alors où et comment savoir où
faire prendre en charge son enfant
lorsqu'on a une crise de bronchiolite
des difficultés respiratoires et bien je
le redis aux parents si vous ne savez
pas si vous n'avez pas de médecin
traitant faites le 15 appelez le SAMU
vous y trouverez des professionnels des
professionnels compétents qui pourront
vous diriger vers le meilleur parcours
de soins pour votre enfant je le redis
qui n'est pas toujours l'hôpital mais
qui est le plus souvent le médecin
traitant je vous invite à aller voir ses
professionnels à Bordeaux par exemple ou
à Créteil éventuellement en ce qui
concerne la problématique de l'hôpital
je vous rejoins nous avons des problèmes
structurels dans notre hôpital ils ne
sont malheureusement pas nouveau
un de mes engagements c'est justement de
travailler sur ces problèmes structurels
globaux de l'hôpital et pas uniquement
bien sûr sur la filière de pédiatrie
c'est ce que porte le PLFSS pour l'année
prochaine dont nous aurons l'occasion je
pense de discuter dans les semaines qui
viennent et je pourrais plus librement
vous détailler l'ensemble des mesures
pour restructurer notre système de santé
à l'hôpital public
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Serge Mériot pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'État en charge de la
ruralité mes chers collègues travailler
même dans la main avec les élus ruraux
vous l'avez promis le 19 octobre dans la
presse ce même jour la MF sortait un
rapport sur la nécessaire préservation
du dispositif des zones de
revitalisation rurale or sur ce sujet
les élus attendent toujours une main
tendue pour l'heure pas de calendrier
pourquoi tant d'opacité de la clarté
voilà ce qui exige la ruralité depuis 95
les ZRR sont un vecteur essentiel du
développement et de l'attractivité de
nos territoires leur fait annoncer à
décembre 2023 inquiète les élus ce
dispositif concerne aujourd'hui près de
14000 communes et un gage 320 millions
d'euros une somme dérisoire au vu des
effets positifs observés sur le
territoire implantation d'entreprise de
médecins d'acteurs économiques bref il a
su contribuer à redonner vie en nombre
de le village le rapport sénatorial
d'abride 2022 et les ruraux saluent son
efficacité à l'instar de l'AMF il vous
demande de reconduire un dispositif
réformé prenant en compte les évolutions
des territoires en concertation avec
leurs élus revenir à l'échelle des
communes et toute une instituée de
niveaux de classement et toute une série
d'autres mesures bref le travail vous
est prémâché
en parlez-vous-en posant les fondations
d'une nouvelle politique de dynamisation
des zones rurales en ces temps troublé
pour les collectivités locales nous
devons les accompagner les concerter et
leur donner de la visibilité aussi
madame la secrétaire madame la ministre
quel dispositif entendez-vous mettre en
place pour pallier la disparition des Zr
quelle place auront les élus dans
l'élaboration de ce dispositif
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la secrétaire d'État en charge
d'argumentalité madame Dominique Faure
vous avez la parole de madame la
ministre
c'est la terre monsieur le sénateur
Serge berioux les zones de
revitalisation rurale les ZRR ont été
créés par la loi d'orientation et
d'aménagement
de la et du développement du territoire
le 4 février 95 et je sais le rôle
déterminant qu'à jouer le Sénat dans
l'adoption de cette loi le législateur a
souhaité prendre en compte les
difficultés spécifiques liées au
maintien d'activités en milieu rural et
de façon plus générale soutenir des
parties de notre territoire qui sont en
des prises démographiques ou économiques
pour atteindre ce but les Ederer ont été
adossés un régime d'exonération fiscale
et sociale aujourd'hui c'est 13712
communes qui sont classées en Zr et qui
représente 16% de la population
française je suis très attaché à ce
dispositif qui prend fin au 31 décembre
2023 et qui reconnaît la fragilité des
territoires ruraux afin de préparer
l'avenir le premier ministre Jean Castex
avait confié une mission parlementaire
au sénateur espanaque et del Crow et aux
députés blancs et barreaux cette
prorogation et cette mission
parlementaire témoigne de notre
attachement commun à ce dispositif
aujourd'hui il convient de poursuivre le
travail que nous avons engagé pour en
définir depuis mon entrée au
gouvernement et dès le 26 juillet
quelques jours après ma prise de
fonction je répondais à l'invitation du
sénateur delcro de travailler sur cette
question le 25 août j'y planchait avec
le président de la MF et certains
membres de son bureau le 8 septembre
avec les co-présidentes de la commission
ruralité de l'AMF cet après-midi même je
reçois officiellement les auteurs de la
mission parlementaire avec Christophe
Béchu nous ferons un premier travail sur
les 14 propositions du rapport vous le
voyez le gouvernement est donc au
travail pour envisager l'avenir des ZRR
nous avons confié une mission d'appui
avec la DGCL à Monsieur François
Philizot inspecteur général et président
du Conseil d'orientation de
l'Observatoire des territoires afin de
faire des propositions avec Christophe
Béchu à la première ministre début de
l'année 2023 ces propositions se
nourriront d'un travail de large
concertation avec le groupe ruralité en
cours de constitution à l'Assemblée
nationale et je l'espère avec un groupe
ruralité institutionnalisé au Sénat si
vous deviez le décider c'est notre
affaire madame la ministre c'est
concertation seront
complète gouvernement continue de
reconnaître la fragilité des territoires
humains s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur
dans mon département lors du congrès des
mers ruraux vous disiez aux habitants du
monde rural qui sont une chance pour
notre pays prouve-le donner l'heure
donnez au territoire ruraux les moyennes
nécessaires tant qu'il est encore temps
merci la parole de notre collègue
Martine Berthet pour le groupe les
républicains
cossignée par élus syndicaliste
représentant des associations et les
locaux et parlementaire nous étions plus
de 200 de toutes sensibilité politique
confondues nous souhaitions rappeler nos
engagements pour le chantier ferroviaire
du lion Turin et notre choix du scénario
grand gabarit pour ses accès à la suite
de la consultation que vous avez menée
le gouvernement devait prendre une
position officielle en début d'année ce
n'est toujours pas fait je vous rappelle
mes courriers restés sans réponse de
plus en l'absence de décision vous
ouvrez une brèche à une minorité
d'activistes qui se disent écologiste
mais sont contradictoires dans leur
discours ils cherchent à effrayer nos
populations par la désinformation en
s'appuyant depuis plus de 30 ans sur les
thèmes à la mode du moment roche
radioactive roche amiantifère et
aujourd'hui avec les sécheresses il
pointe les atteintes aux sources d'eau
pourtant l'entreprise binationale telle
te suit de façon très sérieuse ce sujet
en lien avec les élus locaux c'est par
le faitoutage que nous réussirons à
diminuer nos émissions carbonées et à
améliorer la qualité de l'air dans nos
valises la ligne historique n'en a pas
la capacité et nous devons en parallèle
libérer des sillons pour les transports
voyageurs du quotidien
la légitimité démocratique à faire des
choix qui engagent l'avenir de nos
enfants appartient bien aux élus et non
à une poignée de militants opposés au
projet monsieur le ministre ne vous
laissez pas impressionner prenez les
décisions attendues la question n'est
plus d'être pour ou contre ce tunnel il
s'agit d'un déterminer ses accès et d'en
assurer leur financement aussi mes
questions sont simples quand
comptez-vous confirmer officiellement le
scénario retenu d'autre part l'Union
européenne a annoncé 50% de finance pour
les accès vous n'avez pas postulé à son
appel à projet opération ferroviaire
alors que le percement du tunnel est en
cours quand le ferez-vous
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministres déléguer en charge des
transports monsieur gone merci monsieur
le Président Madame et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice Berthet je
partage pour être très clair avec vous
l'engagement et l'intérêt incontestable
de ce projet il est important sur le
plan écologique vous l'avez rappelé pour
le développement du ferroviaire et du
Fred ferroviaire en particulier il est
essentiel pour les mêmes raisons sur le
plan économique et c'est un grand projet
européen que nous devons faire avancer
il a été d'ailleurs confirmé au plus
haut niveau dans le traité d'amitié
entre la France et l'Italie il y a moins
d'un an les concertations ont été
engagées selon un calendrier que vous
connaissez qui est transparent par le
préfet de région le préfet Pascal mayos
il y a eu concertation avec les élus
toutes les collectivités qui peuvent
être amenées à financer la question des
accès et ce travail s'est terminé au
début de l'année 2022 dès que je suis
arrivé j'en ai pris l'engagement devant
le Parlement dès le mois de juillet j'ai
repris ce travail de concertation pour
que nous passions maintenant la partie
concrète et financière je me suis rendu
comme je l'avais indiqué à Lyon dès le
mois de septembre pour échanger avec
l'ensemble des collectivités des
financeurs j'ai constaté comme vous
l'avez rappelé que le scénario qui avait
la nette préférence de l'immense
majorité des collectivités c'était ce
scénario pour les accès dit grand
gabarit et maintenant j'ai demandé qu'il
y a une concertation et j'ai mandaté le
préfet à cette fin d'ici le début de
l'année prochaine pour qu'en face de
cette ambition ferroviaire il y a une
ambition budgétaire car le scénario
grand gabarit était aussi le scénario
gang gabarit est aussi le scénario le
plus coûteux et donc si les
collectivités sont prêtes à s'engager
nous le serons aussi mais il faut que il
faut que maintenant il faut que
maintenant chacun dise qu'il est prêt à
mettre concrètement de manière sollante
et trébuchante sur la table nous sommes
prêts à nous engager pour se faire et à
mobiliser aussi les financements
européens sur la section
transfrontalière dans le PLF 2023 qui
est bientôt soumis à votre débat des
crédits sont là intégralement toute la
programmation à respecter j'ai eu encore
hier un entretien avec la Commission
européenne pour que les financements sur
cette section transfrontalière soit
rapidement mobilisée il n'y a aucun des
engagement à cet égard et quand le
scénario sur les accès sera arrêté sur
le plan ferroviaire et budgétaire nous
postulons évidemment financement
européen et comme vous l'avez rappelé en
effet l'Union européenne nous a indiqué
qui a été prête à mobiliser 50% des
financements jusqu'à 50% des
financements sur cet accès et l'État
sera au rendez-vous mais il faut que
tout le monde soit au rendez-vous les
collectivités l'étages et pris cet
engagement au nom de l'État au mois de
septembre nous attendons maintenant la
concertation financière décide de début
de l'année je crois que cet engagement a
été pris au mois de juillet il est tenu
merci c'est d'ailleurs dans l'article 10
de du projet de traité que vous allez
examiner mais chers collègues à partir
de 16h30 et donc c'est confirmé votre
vote vous permettra
d'examiner ce point et je me permets de
le souligner
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
François Bonnot pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition énergétique
la crise de l'énergie que nous
connaissons et sans précédent
si la situation semble revenir à la
normale sur le front des carburants
nous devons nous préparer à des coupures
d'électricité et de gaz sans être
certaine c'est coupures sont possibles
la guerre en Ukraine et ses effets
atroces sur sa population étant
malheureusement le révélateur d'une
situation qui se dégradait depuis
plusieurs années faute d'anticipation
pour l'électricité la moitié des
réacteurs nucléaires est encore à
l'arrêt et EDF ne cesse de différer leur
remise en service
à cela s'ajoute les grèves dans les
centrales qui réduisent encore un peu
plus nos capacités de production et
l'effort de maintenance les énergies
renouvelables bien qu'importantes sont
non pilotables en absence de vent et de
soleil et nucléaire ce sont les
centrales à gaz qui prendront le relais
nous approchons de la période hivernale
et certains spécialistes nous annoncent
qu'ils pourraient être rigoureux
s'agissant du gaz nos réserves sont
pleines mais elles ne représentent que
les deux tiers de la consommation
hivernale des PME et des particuliers
les entreprises gazointensives ont déjà
été prévenus qu'elle pourrait avoir à
subir des coupures préjudiciables à leur
activité
les Français sont prêts à faire des
efforts mais accepteront mal de ne pas
être prévenu et alerté à temps ma
question est donc comment allez-vous
procéder vis-à-vis des entreprises pour
les inciter à s'arrêter avec quel délai
et pour combien de temps
comment allez-vous procéder à l'égard
des particuliers des collectivités des
établissements scolaires à quels
horaires selon quel délai comment
organiser ses coupures pour les
situations particulières médicales ou
sociales quelle utilisation ferez-vous
des compteurs Linky
a bien nommé les choses on contribue à
régler les problèmes du pays
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la milice de la transition
énergétique
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Bono vous avez
raison de mentionner cette plus grave
crise énergétique que nous connaissons
depuis les années 70 avec le casier
arrêt des livraisons en Europe du gaz
russe de quoi parle-t-on de 40% du gaz
qui approvisionné l'Europe et qui
aujourd'hui crée un stress sur notre
système énergétique ce n'est pas propre
à la France c'est propre à l'Europe et
nous agissons ensemble en solidarité
dans ce contexte nous avons également à
faire face à une moindre production
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire et
hydraulique du fait des sécheresses que
nous avons connues cet été et pour le
nucléaire vous l'avez mentionné de
soucis de maintenance sur lequel nous
agissons dans ce contexte gouvernement a
pris toutes les décisions pour préparer
le passage de l'hiver dans les
meilleures décisions le stockage de
styoke de gaz les stockages stratégiques
pardon de gazon rempli vous l'avez dit
en France mais également dans toute
l'Europe à l'initiative de la France je
le rappelle l'augmentation de nos
capacités d'approvisionnement en gaz
naturel les stocks sont remplis mais les
terminaux continuent à acheminer du gaz
à pleine capacité l'augmentation de la
puissance de certains barrages
hydrauliques la préservation de nos
capacités de production cet été pour les
réserver à l'hiver je ne vais pas
mentionner toutes les décisions que nous
avons prises pour préserver cet hiver
vous mentionnez la situation d'EDF et je
veux saluer ici l'accord qui a été
trouvé au niveau de l'entreprise d'EDF
et la reprise du travail qui s'est faite
ce week-end pour précisément faire en
sorte que on continue à agir sur les
mathens à remettre en état nos centrales
nucléaires pour qu'elles puissent
produire cet hiver et cela a été fait en
grande responsabilité par les
organisations syndicales et par la
direction d'EDF enfin quelles sont les
actions vous le savez RTE qui est notre
expert en la matière mentionne des
risques très limités de difficultés et
cet hiver c'est l'hiver est normal en
termes de température et donc par
rapport à Siri ce très limité nous
agissons nous avons interruptibilité
effacement sécurisation de nos
interconnexions il s'agissant du
scénario ultime de coupure là encore un
plan est activé et on ne parle que de
deux heures d'interruption par jour en
matière d'électricité je n'irai pas plus
loin mon temps est largement dépassé
monsieur Bono
oui madame la ministre permettez-moi
d'insister sur les coupures de gaz qui
pourraient toucher les entreprises
notamment s'agissant de la durée de ses
coupures il faudra que ce soit vu en
amont et en concertation parce que ça
peut avoir des conséquences très graves
pour ces mêmes entreprises merci
beaucoup
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu le mercredi 2 novembre à 15h
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
de convention internationale la séance
est suspendue